the world's biggest YouTube star yes
even bigger than charlie bit my finger
kid pewdiepie has launched his own
network with the backing of Disney's
maker studios I'm Lucy and let's play
this game spot news update as detailed
in an interview with Variety the network
is called rebel mode and will focus on
nurturing the talents of other content
producers across YouTube Facebook and
other platforms Jude said I started as a
gaming and digital content fan long
before making this a profession the idea
of rebel mode was built from my own
experiences and will aim to bring
together an Avengers like talent squad
to work and grow a business together
rebel mode also aims to diversify the
type of content being produced
delivering everything from traditional
gaming videos to apparel and more rebel
mode will create one-off videos to
original series to gamey games to
animations music clothes charity drives
and more really anything that's awesome
in the eyes of the fans PewDiePie and
maker studios will select the talent
themselves at launch the network
includes cutie pie Marcia cinnamon toast
Ken and Emma blackery as well as
jacksepticeye quibble cop
markiplier Dodger and jelly button--
it's not just about the games rebel mode
will also have a fundraising element and
encourage fans to donate money for
various charitable causes
announcement comes omits rumor and
speculation that PewDiePie could leave
the Disney owned maker studios to
establish a rival Network executive VP
and head of maker studios courtney holt
revealed we're thrilled to be doubling
down with Felix he is an amazing talent
a great partner and the pulse of
millennial pop culture we firmly believe
in his vision for rebel mode and his
chosen creators we can't wait to see the
possibilities ahead so what do you make
of the new network good puter then just
really take on Thanos be sure to let me
know in the comments box below or on
Twitter I'm at Lisa James games for all
the latest gaming news make sure to keep
it GameSpot